yuck shamash dubs a cop JW we got inside
I was someone from Poland and look look
look how the crater set it up for him to
come and look at a mosque but has anyone
ever explained to you what Islam is okay
has anyone ever explained to you I think
I know tell me what does it mean what
does it mean the word Islam would you
mind if I shared it with you I'll take a
couple minutes I don't know because okay
then two minutes one of them okay okay
okay okay I give you France and bring
them to yes okay okay I'm waiting here
see man look at that beautiful the 20 of
these for Dawa always will come up so
the people are coming here from all
different countries and then walking in
perfect opportunities no one's here no
one is here to explain to them to
approach them to ask them do you want to
learn about Islam so we approach this
this traveller from Poland he's gonna be
right back he's gonna be right back and
we're gonna go ahead he's given us a
minute so all we need because he's in a
hurry
we're gonna go ahead and just go over
the very basis of Islam and we'll show
you how just how easy it is to deliver
the simple message and give him a taste
and then if he's sincere and we'll
direct him to call upon a lot to the
Creator
and then from there we'll see Allah is
the one who guides but we got to deliver
the message so yeah so much so I know I
know you guys are in a hurry so I asked
him because he came here Martin and
Simon Simon so I said we made a deal I
said give me a coat a couple minutes he
said I'll give you one and I can go
ahead and explain its lon because it'd
be ashamed that you come in front of a
mosque and you leave you don't even know
what Islam is right okay because it's
the most misunderstood way of life in
the world a lot of media you know the
mass media manipulation and people
started waiting in Salaam with terror
and all sorts of crazy things but Islam
simply means to submit your will
everyone wants peace in life right you
want to be happy right you want to know
your purpose in life so Islam gives you
that purpose and defines it clearly and
it simply means to submit your will to
the creator of the heavens and earth
this would Islam me and a Muslim is one
who submits his or her will to the
creator of the heavens and earth so it's
the belief in one and only one God we
start with that only one God and we
believe that God Almighty out of his
love he sent messengers these messengers
came with the same way of life the same
religion and that was calling people to
submit their will to God not to submit
to a human being not to submit to
materialism nationalism none of these
things that you submit to the one who
gave you life and then God Almighty out
of his love he also he sent his guidance
and today you have so many problems in
the world right we need solutions
so God Almighty Allah he sent the Quran
and this is what we have it today for
anyone who wants to take a look at it
tamper free tamper proof we have it in
this original in the Arabic language
signs upon science for anyone whose the
ingredients are to you're sincere in
your genuine you want to know you had
enough of partying and all the stuff
that you do it's not bringing contempt
easement peace in your life now you want
to go above rise to the next level now
you look at the Quran you say hold on
it's making a claim now you put it to
the test you know it's easy to be funny
you know what I mean it's easy to look
for trouble but if you're sincere you go
and look at it so what we're saying we
covered the belief in one and only one
guide the messengers they got Almighty
sent and the last and final revelation
that we have today the Quran and then in
there talks about preparing for what
comes next so preparing for the
hereafter if you following me everything
makes sense so far they're all we're all
going to be accountable for what we do
in this life is life is short so the
Quran not only gives us the blueprint to
how to live in this life right by being
good human beings not according to my
desires or the years but to how Allah
the Creator told us how to live to be a
good righteous human being establish the
way of life that God Almighty wants us
to live and then you have the day of
judgment and that's where it now is
determined where you gonna live forever
because its life is short you follow me
in short did I pass a minute I think I
almost - so what do you guys think did
you get a clear very short precise but
this is just kind of the fundamentals
the main thing is that you worship the
one who created you do good deeds and be
a righteous human being according to
God's will not our desires any questions
any questions gave you guys something to
think about
a little bit I think a lot of religious
are a little bit similar huh and ever
we people to have people friendly for
everybody - now we have to when we come
to that level now we come to the point
in our lives that because someone says
well what's the difference with all the
different religions right they all make
in certain claims if you want to go into
religions that worship sticks stones and
bones in every religion you will find
creation worship Islam is the only way
of life which calls you to purely
worship the One God any other religion
is calling you somehow to worship the
creation Aslam stands out because it
calls you to worship to what the Creator
that's what separate and makes Islam
unique it's the truly monotheistic
religion now did you know that in Islam
it's the only non-christian faith which
makes it an article of faith to believe
in love Jesus that he was one of the
mightiest messengers ever sent by God
right that he called people to only
worship God just like Moses Abraham and
the last and the final messenger we say
who came Prophet Muhammad he was the
seal of the prophets who came with the
miracle the Quran Jesus did miracles at
his time moses did at his time for a
particular time and place in people but
muhammad came for the polish came for
the year polish for the italian for the
american to the bosnian for all of
mankind with no different message but
the same message worship how do you say
god in poland bull worship folk one god
good thank you for lending me in here
okay and hopefully now you guys can tune
into the show is in chicago we live in
chicago
all right what's your photo but dogs in
public okay all right